this session will be about coding theory
um
and our first speaker will be ronnie
khan from tel aviv university talk about
the joint work with the sagittamo
a about a new
improved way to repair insulin or of
those
using non-ideality
thank you
hi everyone thank you for the
introduction oga
so i'll be talking about nonlinear
repair of read solomon codes and this is
a joint work with uh tahitam
so um throughout all this talk we are
going to discuss only linear codes that
is linear subspace of dimension k
we are going to use the common notation
which we all know
the finite field is going to be right of
order uh q
and we're going to discuss only mds
codes which have the mts property that
the code can correct from any n minus k
erasures
so our work falls into a greater topic
called coding for distributed storage
systems
and you can imagine the following
scenario well you have a file
and you want to store it into the cloud
into this big storage system and you cut
it into k chunks of data each such chunk
is going to be a symbol in a finite
field of order q and these k symbols
together are going to be encoded using
the mds code to an mds
code word
well we see here the code word c1 up to
cn these are the symbols of the code
word and then
each symbol is going to be distributed
to a different server okay so the
pictures looked like that we have n
servers and each node stores a symbol
from the codeword
now a common problem in storage is that
a node fails
and when a node fails we bring up a new
replacement node and its job is to
recover the data that was on the server
that failed
okay so how does he do that he does he
does that using a repair scheme
and basically he receives information
from the remaining nodes okay some
function of the data that they store
well we see here mu1 of c1 mu2 of c2 and
so on
and upon receiving this data the
replacement node basically recovers the
data that was on the that server that
failed
okay now the scheme is going to be
linear if this functions mu 1 up to mu n
minus 1 a linear function and by linear
i mean linear over the base field so
recall that we are working in a finite
field of order q and it has a base field
good
so the main parameter of interest is
going to be the bandwidth
which is basically the total number of
bits transmitted from the replacement
from the remaining nodes to the
replacement node
in the process of the repair
okay
basically it's the following sum right
um and this parameter is
we want to minimize it and we want to
minimize it because in real life
scenario
when a server falls and it is not a rare
incident that the server falls it
triggers a lot of communication in order
to repair it
in order to recover the lost data
and minimizing will eventually over long
periods of time will make the system
more
reliable minimizing the bandwidth
um
good so the first repair that i want to
show you is the trivial repair which is
just using the fact that we use an mds
code basically any k servers any set of
k servers can transmit their symbol to
the replacement node
now upon receiving k symbols
since we have an mds code
the server can
decode the entire code word it has the
entire code word in it particular it has
that symbol
okay that was lost
the scheme is linear trivially
the bandwidth is k times log q
okay
and the question is can we do better in
terms of bandwidth
and this whole area of research started
in the paper of the marquis set all in
2010
and they proved the lower bound which is
called the cathode bound on the amount
of bits that is needed in order to
repair a failed node
okay so d here in the quantity is going
to be the number of nodes that
participate in the repair and if we go
back to the trivial repair the number of
nodes that participated
was k
so if we sign here
instead of d y sine k we are back in the
regime where the bandwidth was k times
log q
but
we see that as d increases k plus 1 k
plus 2 this quantity becomes much
smaller
okay
and
uh another small definition so a code
that a repel scheme with a code that
achieves
this bound with the quality
for any set of d helper nodes
it's called an msr code an msr code
and there are msl codes out there
but we were interested in the code which
is called in
in many ways
the greatest of them all and that is the
read solomon code okay so i'll just i i
think that we all know what ritualman
codes are i'll just say here
uh
the definition is written here but we
were interested in in read someone codes
because ritualman codes are already
deployed
in current storage systems for example
facebook
uses resolument code where n equals 14
and k equals 10.
so
designing repair schemes with better
bandwidth forward solomon codes can find
immediate application in these storage
systems
so of course we weren't the first to
look on ritual codes it started in the
paper by sean mugan ital
which showed that there are ripple
schemes that are better than the trivial
repair scheme for its hormone codes
then guru swami and waters gave
basically complete characterization
of linear repair scheme of free solomon
codes
then based on their work
tamiya and bulk showed
that rs codes are
mkdmsr codes for any kdnn
well problem solved right
but the thing is
that the construction of tamiya enberg
requires a field size of 2 to the 2 to
the n
and they almost uh achieved they
achieved an almost matching lower bound
which says that the field size
has to be 2 to the 2 to the k and this
is clearly
infeasible in practice right we don't
work with such large fields
so the main goal is to reduce the
alphabet size
okay and we started looking at these and
the first thing that came out to our
mind was okay so msr codes and linear
repair
by already swami in 2019 must have large
alphabet size
okay so
maybe turn to non-linear repair scheme
and this was also raised as an open
question in go so i'm in water's paper
what is the power of non-linearity
and our starting point which became this
work was to look at rit solomon codes
over prime fields
and why we did that basically because
there are no linear functions from prime
fields to a proper subset of the prime
field which is linear
right
so
as a conclusion any repair scheme that
outperforms the trivial one
must be non-linear when we talk about
read solomon codes over prime fields
and this is exactly what we did in our
work
we we basically constructed nonlinear
repair scheme as far as we know it is
the first non-linear repair scheme
and um
and i'm going to describe two theorems
so the first one is that almost all
two-dimensional read solomon codes over
prime fields are asymptotically msr code
and i'll say in a second what is us what
means asymptotically here
another theorem is that
another theorem is the construction of
rich solomon codes not for every
regime of parameters but only for k and
d up to n over 2 we show the
construction where any node can be
repaired
using bat with bandwidth that
asymptotically achieves the cuts at
bound
and we know that this construction is
not an msl code
and by asymptotically in both theorems i
mean that
we achieve almost a cuts at bound but
another additive factor of b switch
depends on m and we say asymptotically
because in storage
we think of p the alphabet size being
larger than n the number of nodes
so we provided
also a lower bound
and
and i'm going to um just
skip to the open question since i don't
have much time uh but there also is a
lower bound which
a bit improves the cuts at bound in this
specific regime
good so open question is
basically showing that there are s codes
over prime fields that are
asymptotically msr codes for any nk and
d
also providing explicit constructions
uh we want to show like tamiya and bug
okay for any nk and d provide an
explicit construction of aggress codes
of plan fields
and the final open question is to better
understand the tension between the field
size
and the dimension of the code or the
length of the code
okay
we believe that our work was just
scratching the surface of this entire
field
of non-linearity
and we believe that we can
take our techniques and
employ them also in other codes which
are not only read solomon codes and
designing more non-linear repair schemes
so uh thank you
okay thank you
and thank you for a thank you for being
on time
tight schedule
um
sorry for writing for every run and it's
trying to locate some speaker
um
okay are there any questions
yeah no
just this open your mind
okay uh i was just wondering about the
upper limit of two where that came from
and if you could say a word about your
techniques
again what was the question i didn't
hear
so so uh what was the reason you could
do only dimension two
k equals two
well it was the the easiest uh
case which is not trivial
and
and the word about the techniques um
we basically were looking at um
uh
at uh
okay so so you when you have uh uh
uh
an extension field and a subfield
okay so you you take a subfield and you
um make a subfield plus a subfield you
are again in the subfield okay and this
thing is
highly uh used in
all of the schemes of guru swami waters
and and tamiya embark and we want to
find subset of of prime fields that
have
um similarity to this uh
to this uh structure okay they are not
expanding in sums
so we took basically we took two
arithmetic progressions okay so if you
take an arithmetic progression and you
make arithmetic progression plus an
arithmetic progression
you don't expand very much
and so this is the main idea i recommend
you all to watch the full video which i
discuss
in more details my our techniques
okay thank you
okay i guess we can take more questions
offline sorry we are tight scheduled
thank you
okay so now for our next day speaker
enoch
um
okay so maybe you want to upload your or
share your slideshow
yeah i can't start until the other
participant okay ronnie can you unshare
thank you thank you
can you share now
can you see
yeah i can see okay thank you
okay so our next speaker will be a north
shooti from stanford university
and he will tell us
about a new way to to repair new films
not just a
symbols or code words but linear
functions of a chord words
and
thank you
thank you uh yes so i've titled this
computing efficiently on encoded data
and this is joint work with mary rooters
who's
right there
and
i'm just going to jump right in so yeah
similar to before we have bits i'm going
to say b bits that we want to store and
we have some nodes that we can store
these bits on and the most naive
approach would be without any coding
we're going to just split up the bits
into chunks and put a chunk on each node
and then when we want to recover all the
bits we have a total bandwidth cost of b
bits to recover our bid stream and we're
interested in this talk of in computing
functions of those bits and we want to
save on bandwidth cost whenever possible
so uh
the real problem with this naive
approach is that if something bad
happens to one of your nodes you've just
lost that chunk and you can't recover
those bits and you can't compute
functions that depend on those bits so
we don't use this approach and the we
know the solution to this using error
correcting codes so in this case you
encode your bits in some code uh they
take up more space maybe they are
occupying more nodes but uh but you can
still for uh uh you know reasonable code
like the uh right mds codes you can
recover your original bit string with
just b bits of downloading bandwidth you
can compute arbitrary functions once you
download the bits okay including
repairing repairing a node for example
and if something bad happens to one of
your nodes this is still the case as
long as not too many of your nodes are
lost
uh we focused on the case of read
solvent codes so uh as as ronnie kahn
mentioned in the previous talk these are
very important they're used in systems
like seth and hdfs uh and okay so in
these codes there are k symbols of a
finite field with q elements so each
symbol is represented by log2 of q
fifths not necessarily two just you know
log two cubits so b is k log 2 of q and
we encode in this code
and we were interested in computing
functions uh that look like this so some
sum over i of lambda i times f i where
the f i are the symbols of our finite
field that comprise our message and the
lambda i are some arbitrary coefficients
from that same finite field
so these are linear functions and we
found that if you had encoded in a read
solomon code you can compute these
functions by downloading just little of
b bits regardless of what linear
function you had chosen the bits that
you download may depend on the lambda uh
the lambda i but it doesn't matter what
they are you know you will be able to
find a way of doing this little load b
bits and i found this really surprising
because
naively at the start of this project i
just assumed that an error correcting
code is like a big and bulky suit of
armor that will provide protection uh of
your data but it's it's kind of slow and
bulky uh and it'll be difficult to
compute on your data because you have to
worry about the fact that it's encoded
but our work shows that at least for the
purpose of these linear computations the
reid solomon code is more like the
ironman armor because it not only
provides protection it gives some new
capability uh specifically you can
compute with just b over log b bits of
download bandwidth that's a little ob
you can compute any linear function you
want of your message
so that this is uh only possible because
when you encode in the read solve one
code you're doing some non-trivial
computations and storing the outputs on
all of the nodes so you're able to take
advantage of that
when you want to compute this new
function you're able to take advantage
of this precomputed library of functions
okay
there are a lot of similar problems in
the literature so as just explaining the
previous talk regenerating codes
in which you want to repair some nodes
that have failed and recover their
contents by efficiently querying the
other the other nodes and coded
computation and homomorphic secret
sharing and gradient coding uh all of
these things there's a lot of work in
all of these directions and in in
general you know you have some notion of
encoded data and you have you want to
perform some computation on it and
there's some measure of bandwidth that
you want to minimize
so this is a
common idea and we wanted to study this
to more generality than regenerating
codes so uh we generalized regenerating
codes which which are just a special
class of linear functions for a linear
code when when you want to compute the
the specific codeword symbol that was
lost
and we generalized that now to all
linear functions which we just thought
was a really natural class to consider
so so this is like our new problem and
this is our theorem or this is a special
case of our theorem so
if you just imagine let's fix a rate r
and then some sufficiently large prime
power q
then we'll consider the family of reid
solomon codes that are full length over
f q to the t
so we work over this extension field uh
and and we use every point in that
extension field as our evaluation points
for the read solvent code then for any
set of coefficients lambda 1 through
lambda k we can recover this linear
function lambda transpose f where the f1
through fk were our message symbols
we can do that just by making queries to
the nodes that hold these symbols of the
code word that results from encoding f
and the total download bandwidth is just
proportional to in this
if if we think of q as a constant this
is like v over log b bits at most if the
message has size b bits uh so this is a
improvement of the factor of log b over
this naive scheme of downloading all b
bits
that you would need to recover the
message
and our theorem is more general than
this you can handle some
non-participating nodes or failed nodes
that don't send any data and uh
equivalently you can imagine they never
existed in the first place meaning you
can have fewer than q to the t
evaluation points
i'll just note that our results are the
best when you use the entire extension
field f2 for the t and all the nodes
participate
but you can handle some you know some of
them being gone
and you can vary these quantities like q
and the raid and the number of
participating nodes
of course you can't handle more than one
minus r times n failures or else you'd
have catastrophic data loss
so so that's our theorem and you can see
our paper for the details
um one of the perhaps limitations is is
that yes we must have some extension
field like f q to the t and uh we so we
can't like directly work over a prime
field so we know there is one way to get
around this if you wanted to perform
batch computations uh on t messages that
are each a vector over fpu for some
prime p then you could view those
messages stacked as like one vector over
f p to the t and then you can encode in
some code over this extension field and
you can recover the same linear
combination of all of your messages at
the same time and when you amortize you
know our scheme will save you bandwidth
but you can see the extension field has
just crept back in so you really do need
some notion of this extension field and
why is that well
that you can encode a field element of
an extension field like alpha as some
vector
with t elements in the base field f
little q so so here i'm just writing it
as u u1 through ut
and you can make this play nice with
addition so alpha plus beta and the big
field you get by just adding the
corresponding vectors in this base field
over the base field and this is just
because the extension field is a vector
space over the base field so we just fix
the basis and then we get this mapping
so using this mapping we can we can
describe what a linear scheme is and
this was also mentioned in the previous
talk um so let's say we are a user we
want to recover this linear function sum
over i lambda ifi and and what is node i
going to send us right they have f of
alpha i so that's the evaluation of the
polynomial with coefficients f1 through
fk
and and they've had they have that
evaluated at alpha i well
this is just some element of this finite
field which is an extension field f q to
the t so like we just saw on the
previous slide you can view this as this
t-dimensional vector with elements in f
little q
and what this node will send us is just
some matrix times this vector and
that'll be an s-dimensional vector
instead of a two-dimensional vector so
we get that back and we do something
with it and uh so a
this matrix a that we multiply with is s
by t
and if we can keep s smaller than t then
we've saved on bandwidth versus just
downloading the entire symbol
and that's that's the that's the idea of
like a linear scheme uh but but
in order for it to be linear you also
need to uh do something linear with all
of the things you receive so once you
get this s dimensional vector that's a u
you multiply it by some t by s matrix r
and you have a different r and a
different a for each node that's r j aj
and then you just add everything up so
you'll say the output of the function is
just sum over j of r j times a j u j
okay um so i haven't told you at all how
you find the agents the rj and the aj
and i won't have time to do that but um
you know if you if you found such things
those that would be a linear scheme and
when you add all of these up you have s
bits order s bits for constant q from
each node and the total bandwidth will
be little of b
um if you can keep the rate constant and
q constant and manage to keep s constant
which we do
so
uh the way that we did this at a high
level we found some characterization for
any linear cut we will need to finish in
one minute
sure
thanks
uh yeah which so the characterization
tells you which uh things you can
recover which lambdas in terms of the
row spans of the ajs and then we can
kind of work backwards from uh read
solomon codes to find the arches and ajs
and we end up with b over log b bits and
this turns out to be optimal if you
assume a linear repair scheme so we
showed a lower bound but there is a gap
for the dependence on the rate and the
fraction gamma of failed nodes so the
for future work we suggest finding the
correct dependence on those quantities
generalizing to other parameters genes
like very few evaluation points
beyond linear functions maybe low degree
polynomials uh and perhaps using
nonlinear schemes like uh in the
pioneering work of kanintama that was
just presented before this talk
and again yeah for other codes as well
perhaps so thanks for watching and um if
there's time for any questions thanks
thank you very much thank you for being
on time
hey can you
switch to the open problem
i think
i didn't have time for it
okay thank you
okay any questions
if you have questions you can just open
your mic and ask
what do you think about other functions
like low degree polynomials or should it
would be possible using read solomona
see using our technique you can compute
some
some polynomials
for example each node could square its
contents and then if your k was less
than n over 2 then you just you can view
that as a some
code word in a different code that
represents some other message which is
some polynomial function of your
original message so there's some weird
functions you can compute but
you know to get a specific phenomenon
do you have in mind some other chords
that can do loads of phenomena
uh no i i just need to read uh first i
would read the work of kanata maybe
there's non-linear code or non-linear
repair schemes maybe will be better
suited maybe there is a maybe you could
do non-linear and in our functions
it's just interesting okay thank you
thank you very much so who is next so i
guess it's the expander paper right so
you are next yes
yes okay thank you so maybe you can
share your slides
sure
yeah see them right
are you a good one
okay thank you
so our next speaker will be a
sushen from a
university of science and technology at
china um
and it will talk about a i think a very
surprising result that improves the
well-known parameters of expanded quads
and thank you
thank you for the introduction uh hello
everybody today i will talk about uh
improved decoding of expander code uh
this is based on joint work with a
quantum
uh from pecking university hindi from
johns hopkins and the mingwe
okay
so let me review some basic notations in
coding theory that will be used in this
talk
uh so we will only consider battery
battery coding this uh in this talk of
nurse earn
say the
code words c1 c2 and so on in this
binary code c
and we define distance to be the
minimum hamming distance among all pairs
of card wars in c and then we define log
the size of c dividing by the nulls n to
be its rate
so once we were using this topic that uh
if the distance is 3000 we know the
unique decoding radius of the code c is
half of the so
so this file will be extensive using
this talk okay uh so we will discuss
expanded codes but before um
so let's first define expanders uh so a
expander has two parameters uh the first
parameter alpha and
denotes the size of the subsets that
we're interested in the second parameter
one minus epsilon times d
denotes the expansion
uh we are requiring for the
in the background of the graph so
specifically a bipartite graph with a
vertices on the left and m which is on
the right which is a d regular on the
left
is expanded if for any subset s of size
uh alpha n on the left hand side is
level size gamma s in this torque is of
size at least the size of s itself times
the expansion parameter 1 minus epsilon
times t okay
okay so this is the definition of
expanders or fueling marks
the first thing that uh
so there is a trivial upper bound on the
sides of the neighbor set that's d times
the size of s
so expander requires a very highly known
trivial lower bond on the size of the
navel set for any
subset that's less than alpha
so so a few more uh remarks is about the
parameters usually we think m is the
distance and say m is half of um and
alpha is some constant
um and the second uh for most
interesting for many interesting
applications if something is the most
half uh in this talk that we sometimes
some results uh require epsilon to be
less than one quarter and we also want e
to be a constant
and uh so there are explicit
constructions achieving these parameters
so that's all i want to say about
expanders
so next let me define expander codes
which are well known for the ultra
efficient decoding algorithms
so basically you can think of the
expander as a as a private graph for the
parity checks okay so specifically so a
given expander we will assign
one variable
one boolean variable to each vertex on
the left and then view
each vertex on the right as a priority
check are its labels the
expander codes will just be uh will just
contain all binary strings satisfy all m
parity checks
okay so there are other vertices on the
nerve so the so the so the nurse of the
cold wars is an and the m parity checks
on the right
so
so yeah so so so the one thing i want to
say here is that the the rate of the
expanded code will be a minus m dividing
by n so as long as m is to say half of
one s eight so it's already the constant
so notice things like this is close
related to ldpc codes
while ldbc code requires requires the
right hand to be regular most ldpc codes
are expanded codes
okay
so let me review some previous work uh
so expander codes
as mentioned earlier are famous for the
ultra ultra-efficient decoding algorithm
seminar work by ships and spearman
showed a linear decoding algorithm
called brief propagation so basically uh
basically this algorithm can be called
one minus two epsilon times alpha and
errors for any expander with parameters
so the uh the size of the subsetting
alpha and the expression is one minus
epsilon t one minus epsilon d right
uh so i wanna say uh this provides a
asymptotic good code with linear temp
recording algorithm so in fact um
or that is to the best of my knowledge
or asymptotically good codes with
near-temperature algorithm based on
variance of expanded codes
uh there's a few more remarks is that it
focuses the distance is at least two
times one minus epsilon times alpha m
so you can see a gap between the
decoding radius of uh of of the
algorithm by cipher and experiment and
this distance that's like what that's
like epsilon times alpha and so they are
set so there are two works trying to uh
bridge the gap uh with decoding with the
scientific decoding radius like one
minus three epsilon over two minus over
over one minus two each
times upon
uh
so so while our natural question is
doing uh is to improve the decoding
radius uh so before answering that so
maybe we should try to figure out what
is the best decent bond we can get from
arbitrary expanded
okay
um so our first result shows that in
fact the distance of any alpha and
one minus epsilon d expander code has
distance alpha and dividing by two
epsilon minus some constant
for any epsilon okay
so just uh compared to the previous uh
vocal bond like two times one minus
epsilon times alpha so we have alpha
over two eu so which is better for any
epsilon less than half
and the moreover we show this is tight
if we only use the property of expanders
so there are codes uh with distance of
an over two epsilon plus little but okay
so um so that's all i want to say about
the first result uh we give a better
distance but the next question will be
that given the new bond can we design
ultra efficient algorithms that become
more algorithms
specifically can be get can be decoded
like a
in the order of alpha and over external
arrows
so we should we also show this is a
probable we give a new linear time
algorithm that becomes like three alpha
over 16 epsilon times an error for any
expected codes but we require epsilon to
be less than one quarter for this german
uh so i want to say like this uh
improves all previous bonds like one
minus two epsilon alpha and one minus
three if so
one quarter uh but this fails slightly
short of the uh decoding half of the
distance that that would be alpha over
four epsilon times
so uh so that's our main result so uh so
let me mention one key ingredient in
this uh
uh in in this work that will be
this like size and expansion trade off
uh so so so so so this says that given
any expander say the original parameter
is alpha and one minus epsilon d so it's
actually a expander
for a larger subset for larger subsets
but with worse expansion parameters so
namely uh so you can pick any k greater
than one and look at the subset of size
k times alpha and the expression will
becomes one minus k epsilon times d
okay so you can pick any k for this uh
together was
to get a worse expansion for larger
subjects
so that's the
key ingredient in this work uh so maybe
i do not have enough time so let me just
quickly uh
sketch the proof uh uh so the the proof
uh probably okay two minutes okay
sure uh yeah that sounds good yeah so
the proof sketch for uh for the new
distance fund is just uh it's uh the
basic idea is to uh plug the unique
neighbor's argument with the size
expansion trade-off okay so i will skip
this part because it's relatively uh
standard so let me tell you a little bit
more about the size expression how we
pull the size expression trade-off
so the basic idea the probabilistic
argument about collisions uh so and
certainly remind you of what we need to
do here we know the graph satisfy some
expression for subset of size alpha um
and we want to prove like a slightly
worse expansion for subset of for larger
subsets of size k times alpha
so basically so we know that s here has
a expansion
one minus epsilon times d times the size
of s we want to prove the lower bound on
gamma t
okay the basic idea is like uh if t has
too many conditions i will pick a random
s
in t of size alpha n
and then i would then i will try to
argue s will also have some collisions
which means that uh
the expression of s is not great so this
gives me some contradiction that the two
should not have the t should not have
too many cliches so that's the basic
idea in this proof and then let me say a
few words about the ideas behind the
decoding radius so the key observation
is that in fact we can improve
brief propagation by guessing the
expansion of the arrow set so in
particular so if you remember brief
propagation so we will flip all b's with
one minus two epsilon b wrong checks so
i will replace this by a new threshold
which depends on the expansion of the uh
of the like uh the errors in the
in the stream so
yeah so so that's all i want to say
about our algorithms and
uh so so that's the summary so
we need to finish in one minute okay
yeah so the distance is like as i said
like the distance is like at least like
alpha m over two epsilon which is tight
uh so this is a better distance compared
to the previous focus bonds so we give
ultra efficient decoding algorithms with
radius like three upon almost 16
episodes the new ingredient is the size
and expansion trade-off
uh so just like summary so we have uh so
maybe like the one interesting question
is decoding algorithm for if some
greater than one quarter another regime
will be these decoding algorithms
including ldpc codes and finally maybe
can we get some hardness results from
decoding
the ldbc or xp or
xml
16q
yeah thank you
thank you thank you for being on time
any questions
do you remember correctly that you are
not one okay please ask yeah oh okay uh
sorry uh
have you thought at all about like using
this to improve quantum uh decoders
uh
there's already uh good question uh
uh to be honest like uh
we are we're learning quantum code at
this moment uh we we haven't uh yeah
thank you i also remember that you have
some results uh
about listing funding do you remember
correctly
uh yes uh we do have some yeah we do
have a service in the bottom
right so uh so we show like yeah for
certain regimes uh these are decoding
radius could be larger than standard
johnson so basically the reason that uh
we know this distance is tight if we
just use the expanded property so so we
will look at the johnson bound for this
distance
so we think that's the standard and we
show yeah we can do something
but it's like combinatorial you don't do
you have someone you don't have
algorithmic results right
no algorithm right just
so that's a good question okay okay
thank you
okay so who is next leonardo right
hopefully everyone can hear me and can
see my screen i can hear you and i can
see your screen thank you hey
okay so our next speaker is a
leonardo for gilgano from the institute
for advanced study at princeton right
yes
okay i think that couple of them eh okay
cool
and uh
it will tell us about a a little
programming for
lina
thank you
okay so um
as we have seen in the previous talk so
uh we're focusing on coding theory
rights and and the main main problem
here is that we are trying to send some
code through a a channel that
potentially has a noise and we want to
re uh
resist corruption right
and uh the two main quantities that we
are interested in are are the rate which
is essentially information per bit
and the distance because the distance
measures robustness of our code as we
saw in the previous talk if you have
distance uh a number of air horses
that's less than distance over two
that's called the unique decoding radius
because you can just decode by looking
at the nearest valid code word right
and uh we are mainly interested here in
in actually theoretically correcting
this so in our talk we're not going to
care about operationally decoding this
so uh we're interested in this very
basic question which is how large can
the rate be well the distance is still
large
and in in formulas these are the two
quantities that that we're interested in
so it's humd so it's the size of the
best possible code of distance that we
see and r2 delta is the best possible
synthetic rate when the relative
distance is delta so we are particularly
concerned in this regime where the
distance is delta times n for some fixed
constant delta
now as you might know the oh also i will
say we are particularly interested in
linear codes as we saw these are just
linear subspaces and i will remind you
that distance for these guys is more
easily computed as the minimum hemming
weight of a non-zero code word
now as you might remember the the
classical results of the literature are
first the gv bound so random codes and
random linear codes are quite good so
you can get a synthotic rate that is
one minus the binary entropy of the
relative distance uh both while gilbert
gave with the random code and then we
have a version over the
random linear code
and on the other side we have michaelis
runcie and welch gave the
famous lp bond that gives you an upper
bound that says okay larger than this
rate you cannot have any code so so this
is a
small graph that shows these two curves
so above this green curve we don't have
any codes and below this purple curve we
do have codes and we don't know anything
about the middle
okay so let me uh go into more details
into this lp bond because that's
basically we're trying to generalize the
the approach of the lp bond here so um
here
the lp bound is based of what is called
the del sarti linear program which is
just this linear program here
so at this point is not that important
how this program looks but it's
important that the the reason why this
gives an upper bound is because uh if i
look at the code of distance at least t
i can count with i can compute what's
called sometimes the distance profile of
this code which is just you count the
number of pairs of code words of
distance at least exactly equal to i
and then you plug this into this uh
linear program and you can see that's a
feasible solution uh with value that's
just size of the code which just means
that the optimal value of this guy is
just an upper bound right because
it's just an upper bound for any
possible code of distance d
now what's important to note is that
this is this kind of uh convex
optimization bound is studying two point
interactions and it's very natural to
ask yourself is well if i were able to
look into interaction between more
points
except that than just looking like a
distance of two points
would i have enough information to
perhaps give a better bond and people
have done this in the literature so
shriver gave a three-point interaction
semi-definite program that gives at
least numerically slightly better bonds
later he also improved this to a
four-point interaction sdp
and uh more generally though observe
that you can do a l point interaction
semi-definite hierarchy by noticing that
actually there is a very natural uh
independence number of a graph problem
associated to this and for that guy
you have what's called the last scare
hierarchy now granted the underlying
graph is exponential size so if you just
use the laser hierarchy naively you're
going to have an exponential size
program which is pretty bad but if you
factor the symmetry of those guys
because there's a lot of symmetries
inherited from the heming cube
you actually get something that at least
at constant levels is polynomial size
now
the advantage of the laser here is that
if you were able to actually
run this thing in arbitrarily large
levels you know that this is eventually
complete namely if you were able to run
at level two to the end it would
actually find the precise value of the
best possible code but the disadvantage
is that well first is not a linear
program it's a semi-definite program and
second it's very very hard to actually
analyze
so our work is to actually
address this problem and what we do is
that we are going to provide a
complete
hierarchy of linear programs and it's
not just the hierarchy of linear
programs but it's very structured it's
going to look very much like the del
sarti linear program so that we have
some hope of actually analyzing
now as you might expect from the title
of the talk uh it's really only going to
work well for linear codes for nonlinear
cause the hierarchy exists but it's not
going to be very good
now um what's the idea behind this well
recall that the delusiop was studying
these uh distance profiles which were
like two-point interactions and it was
based on these macquivering inequalities
that
essentially some linear combinations of
these numbers using what are called the
crotchet polynomials now for us we're
going to study l point interactions so
we have the notion of l configurations
which are the following so instead of
keep
keeping track just of the hemming weight
we're going to keep track of heming
weights all possible hemingway's of all
possible linear combinations of any uh l
tuple of code words so if i give you
some tuple of code words the l
configuration is a some function that
maps from subsets of one through l to
natural numbers that simply says for
example if you evaluated that set one
two seven you take the first word plus
the second word was the seventh word add
them together and you compute the
hemming weight and the configuration
keeps track of all these things
and analogously to the distance profile
we have the
l configuration profile of the code in
which what we keep track of is you count
the number of pairs of l tuples in your
code such that the configuration of
their difference is equal to a
particular function g
and the idea is that we're going to
prove some sort of higher order version
of the macboon's inequalities there will
be some sort of crotchet polynomial such
that this kind of uh linear combination
is always non-negative
so what we're going to get is a
hierarchy that looks very much like the
velcro p because we're going to have one
variable for each configuration
we're going to sum over all these
variables we have some normalization
constraints some zero constraints the
macrions inequalities and some
positivity constraints
and our intended solution is of course
the configuration profile of a code that
we saw before
and let me focus a little bit on this uh
restriction here uh this restriction is
just saying well if my code has distance
at least d
then when i do these kinds of counts if
my configuration g is such that there is
a singleton coordinate strictly between
0 and d well the singleton coordinate is
measuring the hanging weight of the
difference of exactly one code word with
one code word so it cannot be between 0
and d so that forces the the counts to
be zero
now
the
the on higher order something different
happens for linear quotes so if if we
have a linear code actually this
configuration profile is more easily
computed by counting the number of
tuples with a certain configuration but
this means that you can actually put up
even more restrictions for linear codes
because if and if i have a coordinate
that's indexed by a larger set and it's
between 0 and d
then i also know that it cannot happen
because this
this set is counting the hemming weight
of a combination of linear of words and
my code is linear so that's also a code
word and it cannot be between 0 and d so
you can actually put more restrictions
and this completely changes how how the
hierarchy behaves let me also point out
that there's a small technicality with
this hierarchy which is the the value
corresponding to the solution is
actually size of the code to the l so
you actually have to distract left word
but this is just a technical detail
now let me uh just tell you what are
these higher order projects so this this
is the usual project and the usual uh
mac williams inequalities and as i said
we have a higher order version of this
and it's a more complicated formula uh
and i don't really want you to
understand what this means but i just
want you to look and see that the
similarity of these two expressions like
this is just an alternating sum of
products of binomials this is going to
be some alternating sum of products of
multinomials and what i want you to get
from this is that there is an efficient
way of computing this this can be
computed in polynomial time assuming
that l is constant
and if you know a little bit about
association scheme theory it turns out
that these higher order crotchets are
the q functions of some specific
association scheme so they have similar
properties to the usual projects like
orthogonality reflection and recursion
relations
let me just finish by uh actually
stating our theorems so the first one is
that this hierarchy is actually complete
uh in the following sense so as i said
it does give an
upper bound for any chord but by level
about n squared you can prove that the
upper bound is not really that far from
the true value of of the best possible
code
this is when you use those extra
inequality
restrictions that correspond to linear
quotes now if you don't use those extra
restriction and you're studying
nonlinear codes it turns out that this
hierarchy is complete garbage it has all
the values being the same so it
completely collapses
but so so you should really use for
linear quotes and let me finish by
saying that even though it's not in the
paper that was submitted here now we
have even more complicated proof that
shows that the hierarchy is actually
complete not by level n squared but by
level n
and it's not even approximately complete
this precisely completely finds the
correct value of of the best possible
code
uh and that's that's all that i had to
say thank you
thank you thank you for being in time
any questions is
hand raised i don't know if it's
a mistake
so do you know there are any concrete
situations where this uh actually gives
you something a better bound
yeah we so we we did run uh numerically
for some very small instances of n uh
and d and it seems that it it mildly
beats the shriver bound at least
numerically but uh it it's not it's not
very practical to run this hierarchy on
very high levels we run on level l
equals two uh higher levels it seems
like the complexity gets
very bad very fast even though it's
still polynomial
we are really one we really want to
propose this hierarchy to to get
actually an analysis of it rather than
actually run it
another quick question so
you mentioned this distance profile but
uh
you could look at the uh orbits of the
actions on on l tuples and it won't be
the same
it won't be the same so actually gohan's
result on the laser hierarchy uh she's
just looking at those orbits uh on the
laser hierarchy and the the problem is
that once once you factor the symmetries
you don't get a diagonalizable algebra
so you stay with the semi-definite
program
this another way of seeing our result is
to say well what if you drop some
constraints on the laser hierarchy so
that you have more symmetries that when
you factor you actually get a
diagonalizable algebra so so this is one
way of seeing our work
and and you want to retain completeness
and you do retain completeness
okay
okay thank you
um
okay so i think we are approaching our
last stop
jessica
yes hello
um sadly my webcam just broke so the
[Music]
sound has to suffice so we really
imagine you are there okay so but can
you share your slideshow yes
oh okay can you see it
the slideshow yeah okay
okay
oh sorry
maybe i'll introduce you thanks yeah uh
okay great
okay so our last stop will be uh
by jessica
dude
public.com pronounce it quickly
um
from a
a
cispa helmut center
and this will be more about the
applications of of codes to cryptography
thank you
yes thank you very much i'll be talking
about algebraic restriction codes which
is something um
we defined in this paper
um so and
those are my co-authors
so
imagine you have a device
and you want to input two vectors x0 and
x1
and it publishes a scalar
affine function of those two
vectors a times x0 plus x1
that's what it's supposed to do however
it can misbehave and instead of
multiplying by a scalar multiplied by an
arbitrary matrix a so this will become a
multivariate affine function instead of
a scalar one
and this is what
we want to prevent this
while still allowing the above above
behavior
so what we do is
we randomize
x0 and x1 using some encoding function
and
some randomness r
and
turn those into x0 hat and x1 hat and
give those two vectors to the device
then device the device can
multiply use the
affine function to evaluate
and get x zero hat plus x one hat
and now we can we can also publish r
and then the public can reproduce
um
a times x zero plus x1
and as they
were supposed to learn
however if you if the device misbehaves
and
uses a matrix which
is not just a
scalar function
scalar affine function then the public
cannot
reproduce any value
dependent on
x0 and x1 even with knowledge of r so
this is this is uh what the algebraic
restriction code does
um more generally
we have two sets
f and g f is a subset of g
and
we want to allow the functions in it we
want to allow functions in f
and disallow the functions that are in g
but not in f
so
the syntax of our algebraic restriction
code is
you take some input x and some
randomness r produce a
encoded input x hat
and then you can evaluate a function
from f or g on it and get an encoded
output
now this encoded output can
be decoded using the same randomness and
you get y
and if the if the algebraic restriction
code is correct
then this y that you get in the end is
the same as if you evaluated this f
function
on the original input
however if you use some function outside
of f
then y should be uniformly random and
not contain any information about x
this is the
definition i i am not going to go into
the constructions are
we have
we have two constructions
of algebraic restriction codes
one which
allows for
scalar effin functions
where f is are the scalar fn functions
and
g are the multivariate defined functions
and we have one where
f are
multivariate linear functions and
g are all compressing functions and this
is our
i think the
technical crown jewel of the paper
and um
in a way you you need this compressing
um
property otherwise you can always
reconstruct x0 and or you can always
reconstruct the input from the output
uh
yeah okay um
we we apply this in cryptography in a
oblivious transfer protocol
a quick recap of what's uh an oblivious
transfer protocol
it's a
protocol where we have two parties a
sender and a receiver
the receiver has
contributes a choice bit b and the
sender contributes to strings and 0 and
m1 and in the end
the receiver
learns mb however she does not learn
the other n so m1 minus b and the sender
also learns nothing about b
this is a
very important protocol in secure
multi-party computation
as it is
sufficient to do arbitrary secure
multi-party computation
using algebraic restriction codes we get
a
oblivious transfer protocol under the
ddh assumption which has a
very nice properties
namely it is rate 1 which means this
oblivious transfer to message is
as good as it gets
it is statistically sender private two
mess only two messages are exchanged
and we don't need any setup assumptions
so
no
common reference string or random oracle
model
to explain this protocol i'll first go
into
what's a linearly homomorphic encryption
which is something that we use
and a linearly homomorphic encryption is
a kind of public key encryption scheme
with special properties
in a public key encryption scheme you
have two keys a public key pk and a
secret key sk
and you can use the public key
to
encrypt a
so in our scheme you can use the public
key to
encrypt a message which is a n by n
matrix over
the integers modulo p
and then you get a ciphertext c
and now if you use the secret key to
decrypt it you should get back the
matrix now the special the specialty of
linearly homomorphic encryption
is that
um
you can modify this ciphertext
uh use it using two
vectors a and b
to get a new ciphertext c prime
and if you decrypt this ciphertext
you get
m the original message times a plus b
now
um
using this we want to construct a linear
oblivious transfer protocol
and this seems pretty easy
you just take the choice bit b
multiply a
identity matrix to it
and encrypt it and send the ciphertext
and the public key
to the sender
the sender can then evaluate the
function
a fine function of
m1 minus m0
and m0 on on the ciphertext then get a
new ciphertext c prime and send this to
the
receiver and the receiver can simply
decrypt it and we'll get this value
which is exactly mb
however in this scheme that
in this lingerie homomorphic encryption
scheme that we
use for this
let's go we need to finish like in one
or two minutes okay yeah i uh
be done soon
um
we
the
receiver can misbehave and choose a
matrix which is not just a scaled
a scaled identity
identity matrix and this is exactly what
we do
use the algebraic restriction codes for
so instead of
instead of just inputting the
m0 and m1 we encode them get m0 head and
m1 hat
and now um
the sender the receiver still behaves
the exact same way she encrypts the
identity matrix and sends it
and
now the
sender will
use those encoded values and send send
them back
and the receiver will learn this
this function and
air gets mb head
as she can then decode mb hat and get mb
however if she misbehaves and
uses a bad matrix
she will not get any
result dependent on
m0 and m1
because of the security properties of
the algebraic restriction codes
uh yeah
that's it
for further details about the algebraic
restriction codes and the
cryptography around this construction
please check out our paper and i'll take
questions
okay thank you and thank you for being
on time
and we're a bit over time maybe if
there's just one quick question or
something
okay since we are anyway over time maybe
maybe we should stop now so uh thank you
everyone thank you all the
sessions speak speakers of the se
thanks bye